Hello friend, when I was giving
interviews then first I face rejection
in interviews and then I get the
important questions from the interview.
But why to face rejections if we already
have the important questions. So today
I'm going to share you the top 25 most
asked AWS interview questions. If you
are new to AWS then don't worry I will
explain each question step by step like
this with simple diagram and definition
so that you will understand everything
and if you are experienced in AWS then
just sit back watch and revise your
answers completely maybe you are missing
some important information right by the
end of this video you will be able to
answer most of the questions s in your
AWS interviews because these are the
most important and common questions
asked in AWS interviews. So what are we
waiting for? Let's start with the first
question.
What is cloud computing? What is AWS? By
the end you will feel 100% confident on
both of these concepts. Imagine you have
developed one application which is live
on production and this user is accessing
your application right now. Your user
will type the URL in the browser and
through the internet the request hits
your front end application server which
can be in Angular, React or JavaScript.
This front- end server then passes the
request to your backend server
application which might be int net java
or node. Now if any data is required the
back end will request the uh to the
database server and finally send the
response back to the user. Right? And
yes sometimes this front end and this uh
API server or back API back end are same
thing. API server can be the single one
server which can be the monolithic
application also. Okay. So this is how
your this is how your on premises
infrastructure is set up. Okay. This is
onremise application. Onremise means
that your company has to purchase these
servers and maintain these servers
physically inside their own office or
own data center.
Okay, now listen carefully. Instead of
maintaining these servers physically
inside your company, the other option is
your company can use the cloud computing
platforms like AWS, Azure, Google Cloud,
etc. In cloud platforms, all the servers
and the database and many more services
are already present. your company has to
just use them through the internet.
Okay. For example, to host a web
application like this, same like this,
you can replace this physical servers
with AWS
EC2 instances like this.
EC2 in short are just like physical
servers only and they can also host your
application in the same way. So instead
of maintaining the and instead of
maintaining this physical database here
you can use the AWS database which is
called RDS. Okay AWS RDS which is again
the same RDBMS
but it is present in the AWS. Okay I
will explain this EC2 and RDS in
upcoming questions in detail. So that's
it. This is simple cloud computing where
your servers and database and many other
services are present already in the
cloud in the AWS servers and you just
have to access them via uh internet.
Okay, internet remember so cloud
computing remember this is a concept and
Azure AWS Google cloud are implementing
those concepts they are the practical
implementation
so for uh example in this case AWS uh
EC2 and RDS are located in Amazon data
centers across the world okay inside the
AWS cloud computing
and your company And many other
companies can use these servers via
internet connection by subscribing those
services. So that's why now your company
do not have to maintain physical
servers. These physical servers not not
required. Physical databases not
required. Okay. Just internet connection
is required. So that's it. Now let's
conclude conclude easy to remember
definition. What is cloud computing?
Cloud computing is the delivery of
computing service. It's a concept like
servers, storage, databases, networking,
software, AI over the internet
instead of using the physical hardware
or local server.
Clear? So I will explain I will explain
all the storage, database, networking
services, cloud in AWS in the upcoming
question. Okay. Now what is AWS? Here is
the definition. AWS is a cloud computing
platform provided by Amazon offering a
wide range of services for building,
deploying and managing applications and
infrastructure.
So you need not to worry about the
infrastructure. AWS provides all the
services related to infrastructure. You
just have to use them via internet
and your company do not have to maintain
physical onremise server now. So this is
one advantage of AWS that your company
do not have to maintain the servers. But
there are many more advantages of AWS
and that's exactly what I will explain
in the upcoming questions. the five
advantages of using AWS which you must
must know and in the upcoming questions
I will keep the diagram on the right
side and the super simple definition on
the left side so that if you want to
revise quickly later for your interviews
then it will be super easy to do that
from this book also
and yes many candidates have accepted my
never give up challenge and got success
in interviews. You can be the next one.
Type never give up in comments to accept
the challenge and share your success
story when you make it.
What are the five advantages of using
AWS over the onremise servers or you can
say why to use AWS at all? Now you are
going to master this answer. Here is the
same example where a user is accessing
the front end and the back applica back
back end applications from using in AWS.
Okay. So first clear advantage is
costsaving. Yes. For example, your
company has now 10 applications and uh
to host them they have p purchased 10
physical servers. But tomorrow if your
company has only five applications that
means five purchased physical servers or
system are waste only five you need. So
rest five are waste for you right for
your company. So but AWS provide pay as
you go model meaning if you use the
servers then only you pay if you don't
need the remaining five you don't pay
for that okay otherwise you just you can
just immediately remove this EC2 servers
from your AWS account if you don't need
it no need to pay for anything which you
are not using no maintenance cost or for
these physical servers, Amazon will take
care of all the maintenance. Okay. So
that is the topmost first advantage and
the same thing is written here also.
Second advantage is suppose you are
hosting an e-commerce application on
your uh physical onremise servers and
more website users are visiting your uh
e-commerce application on weekends
Saturday Sunday the load will increase
immediately right for that why should
you buy extra physical server just for
the weekends okay just use AWS cloud and
there the servers for the these EC2 in
instances will be automatically added
when the load will increase
automatically okay that's possible that
is called autoscaling and that concept
is horizontally scaling and uh so after
on Sunday these EC2 instances will be
added on Monday load will be less the
EC2 instances will be automatically
removed from your account Okay, that's
great and I will explain these concepts
in detail in upcoming question. But this
is the advantage and same thing is
written here also. Uh autoscaling and
flexibility automatically increases or
decreases resources based on demand.
Instant loads can be handled. Okay.
Third advantage is high availability.
Very simple. AWS offers 99.99%
uptime with their service level
agreement. They assure you which me
which means AWS guarantees you to keep
your servers always on and available.
Okay. Fourth advantage is disaster
recovery. In case of any disaster,
automated recovery and data backup will
be provided by the AWS
because your data is stored in multiple
AWS data centers or availability zones.
If one data center will fail, another
data center will provide the backup.
That is how it works. Whereas if you
have the on-premise servers, uh you will
need you will you would need to manage
the separate backup servers manually on
your own. Right?
Finally, the fifth advantage is advanced
security.
AWS uses AI AIdriven threat detection
encryption multi-layer security which
you don't have to even think about. They
are providing it and you are just using
it. you don't like IM access policy
multiffactor authentication I will
explain them in upcoming questions but
that is an advantage okay so in short
you do not have to u bothered about like
uh security hacking or malware okay
all right I hope now you understand
completely why we should use AWS cloud
instead of the uh onpremise servers
right now. Yes, in the upcoming
questions I will explain how to
practically achieve all these features
like the security, scalability,
availability, how to achieve this in AWS
in the upcoming questions. So be ready
for it.
What are the main cloud service models?
Explain the difference between is pass
and SAS with AWS example. Now maybe you
have heard about this before but today
after listening to the answer you can
explain this to anyone. Okay let me give
you my own example. So when I was a
developer, I was 90% time focused on the
application code and the database. But
but but to manage one production
application from start to end, many
things are needed to manage an
application in your company. This full
computing stack is required. Here are
different layers. Okay. At the top this
developers are handling this application
and data. This is managed by developers.
Okay. Then there is the IT or the infra
team who in do the bottom task like the
runtime runtime like for example you
install Java runtime, net framework on
the server, NodeJS frameworks. So that
done by the IT then your application
might need some middleware middleware
like MS office uh some third party
software your application need MS office
SAP or something other some other API
okay below that OS like Windows server
your application is hosted or the Linux
server so that IT team will install then
virtualization is required to simulate
the hardware. Okay. Then physical
servers definitely where your
application will be hosted. That
physical server must be secured, updated
and monitored, right? And IT team will
also install the antivirus to uh secure
your servers. Next, we have the storage.
storage because your application have
some images, they have some files, it
have some files, some database. So, some
storage on the uh server is required.
And finally, the networking part.
Networking on server is required to
connect all the servers databases
together. So this is the entire setup
from runtime to networking which is
handled by the IT or the infrastructure
team. So both developers and IT team
work together for your company. Okay.
Meaning this fully onremise setup is
handled and managed by your company own
only. Okay. And honestly it's a lot of
work. Now AWS or any other cloud
platform provides three major cloud
service models to lighten and to make
your work simpler your company work.
First model is AAS infrastructure as a
service. In infrastruct IAS
application data runtime middleware OS
will be managed by your company. Okay.
But virtualization, server, storage,
networking will be managed by AWS. So
your company work is less now, right? So
infra uh basically infra team has less
work to do, right? Second most popular
is platform as a service. This is the
most plat uh popular cloud uh model.
Okay. Here your company mostly focused
on application and data only. Okay. Rest
of the things runtime, middleware, OS,
networking, server, storage, everything
is managed by AWS. Okay.
Third model is software as a service
SAS. And here everything is managed by U
AWS including the application and the
data. Okay. Your company just have to
subscribe and use this software. For
example, if you have heard about Amazon
workmail or sales force or office 365,
these are SAS platforms. Your company
just uses these services as a user. Your
company do not have to develop code or
configure anything in the AWS. No
technical work is required in SAS. Okay.
So that is the simple story of IAS pass
and SA uh SAS. And now listen carefully.
All these are just we discussed this
application data runtime. These are
layers not actual AWS services.
Each layer includes some specific
services. For example, there is a
service Amazon EC2. It is the part of
the servers.
Okay, servers server layer. So, Amazon
S3 or EBS are actual services and part
of the storage layer. Okay. So as a AWS
developer you will mostly working on the
implementing AWS services not the layers
layers needed for the understanding.
Okay. And in the upcoming question we
will focus on services not layers. But I
hope now layers are clear to you. And
also you know you know that mostly you
have to work if you are a AWS developer
you have to work on IE or pass because
onremise is completely different. It is
physical servers. It's not cloud and SAS
AWS uh developer do not have to do
anything. It's just a service which your
company has to do directly. That's it.
Okay, great. So that is the whole idea
of these three cloud models. If it is
clear to you, write crystal clear in the
comments or chat box that will boost
your confidence and help you remember
this forever.
And yes, I have also added minimum
definition and description of all the
layers in this book. So that I already
explained it uh but yes I have given it
here in the book so that if you later
want to revise then you can revise
quickly from the book. Okay again don't
try to memorize it. So it's not needed
but try to understand it. Okay.
Now here is a short question. What is
the AWS shared responsibility model? I
already explained this is pass SAS
diagram in previous questions and you
already know that now in cloud your
company have to do the minimum work. AWS
will take care of many things. Okay. So
this division of responsibilities some
part will your company will do some part
will AWS will do is the AWS shared
responsibility model very simple meaning
your company is sharing some work
responsibility with AWS that's it the
same thing is written here but now may
you ask how your company can use and
interact with the AWS services and data
I will explain in the upcoming question.
Before moving forward, ask yourself just
one thing. What is the point of learning
AWS if you can't crack the AWS
interviewers? That's why I have created
a complete AWS interview preparation
boot camp for you with three powerful
tools. Number three, 200 plus AWS
interview questions from all the topics
step by step. Even if you are AWS
beginner still you can learn everything
here also the real scenario- based
questions are covered. Then in this
smart excel you can mark questions
prepared or not prepared and therefore
you can track your interview preparation
progress like this. Second tool is this
PDF book for quick revision just before
your AWS interviews. And first tool is
10 AWS mock interviews to help you
practice just like the real interviews.
Many students have already cracked
interviews with my courses. You can be
the next. Remember just one missed
question can lead to interview
rejection. Why take the chance then?
Check out all the links in the
description if interested. If not, no
worries. Let's move to the next
question.
What are the main categories of AWS
services? What are the top 25 services?
Now, let me show you first AWS
management console. Here it is. If you
log into AWS, then this is your AWS
cloud console where you can use the AWS
services. Here, if I will click this
view all services of AWS. Okay. See all
these are like this compute uh developer
tools machine containers storage and
many more these are the categories okay
and now each category have many services
this compute have EC2 light sale many
many services okay so in short there are
hundreds and hundreds of services
provided by AWS but but but it's not
possible for anyone to learn or use all
of these services right that's why now
let's come back to the slide and here I
will list top 25 AWS services that are
the most important and used 80% of the
time in your application you can build
80% of the application by using this
just 20% services
first category is compute service second
category is database. Inside this we
have the main services also I have
written here. Then we have storage. Then
we have networking and content delivery
category. Next messaging and integration
and the security services. And the last
one is the infra and devop services.
80 to 90% of the application only need
these services I have written here. So
for example, if you want to de if you
are a developer then you need to host
your application you can use this EC2 or
you can oh sorry or you can use the
elastic bean stack or lambda or ECS.
Okay if you want a database you can use
RDS. So I will explain all of these
services one by one in upcoming
questions so that you do not have any
confusion in these services at least and
most importantly I will explain when to
use which type of services when to use
EC2 when to use elastic bean stock for
hosting the application okay so based on
the situation it is required now
that is the important thing and these
services we are going to learn in the
application question uh applica we are
going to learn in the upcoming question
and let's move on
what is hybrid cloud let me give you a
very simple example imagine you have a
very old e-commerce application
now your company has migrated e
application in onremise okay now your
company has migrated the application to
the AWS cloud with a front end and
backend servers something hosted in the
ECT EC2 instances of the AWS like this
and the user is accessing the
application from the front- end server.
Okay. But there is one problem. Uh
although you have migrated the
application servers but your company
could not migrate the database server
which is still present in your company
office or onremise or data center
something like this. Okay. It is
separate and isolated inside your
office. The reason for not migrating
this database can be anything. Maybe
your company does not yet fully trust
the
uh AWS for critical data. Okay, your
company has some banking information
something very they want to be keep with
them only or maybe your data is very
large and it is very complex to migrate
all at once. Any reason for not
migrating the database? Now in this
situation you can use the hybrid cloud
model. For that you can use AWS direct
connect or AWSVPN
uh to securely connect your AWS hosted
application to the with your onremise
database like something like this. Okay.
So that is the hybrid approach meaning
half cloud and half onremise.
Clear? And here is the simple and easy
to remember definition. Hybrid cloud
means combining onremise infrastructure
like your own data center or server with
AWS cloud services. So they work
together.
This definition in the book will help
you in revising the concept.
What is a resource in AWS? What is the
difference between a resource and a
service? Yeah, I know it sounds very
easy, but I don't want to take any
chance with any confusion. So, let's
quickly understand it. Let's go to my
AWS AWS management console. Here it is.
Here, for example, to host your
application, you need EC2 instance. So,
here is EC2 instance. Let's press it.
And
here it is. Now you will find the launch
instance option for EC2. Now listen
carefully. When I press launch instance,
that means an instance of the EC2
service will be created in my AWS
account. Okay, that specific instance we
call a resource. So basically after
creating the resource I can use it for
any purpose in the cloud. For example I
can host my application inside that EC2
instance and in the same way I can
create multiple resources in my AWS
account for different different services
also like uh RDS instance for database,
S3 instance for storage, lambda instance
for serverless function. So that's how
now let's go back to the slide.
For example, this is your AWS cloud and
there are many services available here
like this elastic pen. Okay. Now your
company a AWS developer can use any of
these services by creating instances of
them like this. Okay. And those created
instance in your company account are
called resources.
Okay? And you can name them as per your
convenience.
So if you are a developer just
understand it like uh AWS service is
like a class and AWS resource is like an
object or instance of that class. Great.
Now you are 100% sure what is a service,
what is a resource, what is the
difference. Here is the easy to remember
definition. AWS service is a tool or
feature offered by the AWS to perform
tasks like computing, storage, network
security.
AWS resource is an instance of that
service that you create, configure and
use in the cloud. For example, AWS
services like a class, AWS resources
like an object or instance of that
class. Okay. Now, this simple diagram
and theory in this book will help you in
the quick revision for your interviews.
Now, for a single application hosting,
you have to create many many resources.
Now how to manage those resources that I
will cover in the upcoming questions.
What are AWS regions and availability
zones? How they are different? From the
name itself you can understand region
means a some physical location. So for
example here is the world map and it
shows the reason these dot shows the
regions or the geographical locations
where AWS has multiple data centers. So
the all these dots blue dots are the
regions. Okay. Now as I mentioned
earlier your company do not need to
maintain physical servers in its
offices. No onremise servicesers right?
Instead your company can simply
subscribe to and use cloud resources
from AWS via internet and your company
have to choose the AWS region which uh
location is closer to your company so
that uh the users of your company can
get faster access. Okay, here is the
definition.
AWS region is a geographical area where
AWS has multiple data centers.
Now what is availability zones? Within a
single AWS regions, there can be phys
multiple physical separate separate data
centers. These are called availability
zones. Remember AWS regions means AWS
services are fully available in a
location. For example, in Mumbai, in
North Virginia, Singapore, these are the
regions. But the actual physical data
center location within each region are
the availability jones. So there are
multiple data center present inside one
region. That is possible because if
tomorrow one data center is failed then
other data center will immediately
provide the backup. Right, here is the
definition.
A AWS availability zone is a physically
separate data center within a AWS
region. It ensures high availability by
protecting your application from failure
in a single data center. And that's the
answer to this question.
What are AWS compute services? Name a
few of them. Now listen very carefully
to the answer. The answer is AWS service
that do computations are called compute
services.
Uh let me explain it. Okay. See compute
services are those services that handle
computations. Computations means
processing or executing your application
logic. Like uh you have processor in
your computer to process programs. Same
way for example
here are some AWS comput services
popular one. So Amazon EC2 elastic
compute cloud is an AWS comput service
here because you can use it to it as a
server to host and process and execute
your applications. Okay. Then adep uh
AWS Lambda is used for serverless
computation. Then AWS elastic beanto is
also used for deploying applications
without managing infrastructure.
And then EC2 autoscaling is there for
you know used for scaling the EC2
instances automatically.
Now don't worry I will explain this in
detail in upcoming question but for now
just understand that these services are
used for computation processing and
that's why they are called AWS compute
services. Okay, here is the final
definition.
AWS comput services provide cloudbased
processing power, autoscaling and
execution environments for applications.
That's it. Now in the upcoming question
we will understand the first and very
important compute service and that is
EC2 in detail.
What are Amazon EC2 instances? When
would you use them in a project? To be
very short and simple, EC2 are just like
the servers where you host your
application. Here is a very simple
diagram. You have hosted one application
which is front end is hosted on this
physical server. Okay. And back end or
API server is hosted on this separate
physical server. Similarly, this is
onremise application. Similarly in the
AWS CLU cloud we call these servers as
the EC2 instances like this. EC2 stands
for elastic compute cloud. In short
mostly we use EC2 instance to host
application
but like you can use the server for many
other purposes. Similarly, you can also
use EC2 instances also for many other
purposes like running the background
processes and others. It's just like a
CPU. Here is the simple and easy to
remember definition.
EC2 instance are cloudbased virtual
servers that allows to run application
without needing to buy or manage
physical hardware. That's it. Now you
may ask is EC2 is the best and the
simplest and the fastest for hosting
application.
The answer is no.
So which one is the best for hosting
application that I will share in the
upcoming question.
What are the differences between
horizontal and uh horizontal and
vertical scaling? When to use what? Both
of these concepts are closely related to
EC2 instance in the cloud. Let's take a
simple example. Suppose you have the EC2
instance and your application is hosted
over there. Now after some time due to
heavy traffic your website starts
getting overloaded.
Now you need more EC2 instances to
handle the traffic otherwise this single
EC2 instance will be overloaded and
crashed right for that you can add more
EC2 instances like this and then the
incoming traffic is automatically
distributed equally among these
instances
using a load balancer.
So this concept is called horizontal
scaling or scaling out load balancer I
will explain later in detail. Now the
other option is vertical scaling. Okay.
In vertical scaling instead of adding
more EC2 instances you increase the
power of the existing and single one EC2
instant. For example, you can add more
CPU, more RAM, more storage to the same
EC2 instance. Okay, like this. So you
are making the EC2 instance bigger.
Okay, so that is vertical scaling. Here
are the differences between them. In
horizontal scaling, you add more EC2
instances. In vertical scaling, you are
increasing the size of single EC2
instance. So now the real interview
question is when to use what? Here is
the answer. Horizontal scaling is best
for stateless applications like uh
microservices, web APIs and distributed
systems. Whereas vertical scaling is pre
preferred for stateful application or
monolithic application. Okay. because
hosting stateful monolithic apps in
separate EC2 instances is not possible.
So and yes there is one more difference
and that is horizontal scaling in AWS is
more cost effective as autocaling is
possible using autoscaling groups
and uh load balancer is possible in
horizontal scaling whereas vertical
scaling is expensive and it is limited.
You cannot increase the size of an EC2
instance as much as possible. Right? It
has a limit to increase the size of a
single EC2 instance. Right? In short,
horizontal scheduling and microservices
architecture is better. That's it. All
these differences are written clearly
here in the book so that you can later
easily revise. Now you may ask one
question. What is this autocaling
groups? Okay, so don't worry that I will
explain in the upcoming question.
What are AWS autoscaling groups or ETC2
autoscaling?
Now I have already explained the concept
of horizontal scaling. Here if your
website is hosted in the AWS cloud and
if the traffic increases then you can
handle the load by adding EC2 instances
manually more. Okay, you can add any
number of instances EC2 but here is the
problem. What if someone forgets to add
the EC2 instances during high traffic
then the application will crash right?
Or if the traffic is very low but no one
removes the extra EC2 instance then you
have to pay the unnecessary cost of that
extra AC2 instance right because that
server is ideal idle but it is still
running. So as a better solution instead
of instead of manually adding or
removing EC2 instance
you should use the auto scaling group
ASG service in AWS. Okay. So it is
better to because it will automatically
there is no manual thing if the traffic
will increase it will automatically
increase the EC2 instance. So in your uh
in AWS account you do not have to add
EC2 instance. You better add Amazon EC2
autoscaling. Okay. Here is the
definition.
An autoscaling group service is a set of
EC2 instance that automatically scale
based on traffic or custom rules which
you can set. Okay. Now initially as I
said your
uh this um ASG auto scaling group will
have just one EC2 instant and initially
but when the traffic increases it will
automatically keep on adding or if the
it is not required traffic is less goes
down the extra EC2 instance will be
automatically removed also.
In short, you do not need to manually
create or delete EC2 instance. That is
not your headache. Now AWS take carees
all of it for you. And that is the
beauty of autocaling groups. That's it.
Here is a short question. What are EC2
instance types? Now, this is not a very
important question, but uh based on your
need, you can create different types of
EC2 instance in AWS. So here is the
table. Don't try to memorize it. Just be
aware that uh there are many types and
the most famous one is this T family
which because it is a very general
purpose and it is low cost also most
organization use this if they are new in
AWS. If so if you are not sure then go
for this T family. Okay. And yes don't
try to memorize it. Just you have to
know that there is a T family which you
have to use for EC2 instance types and
there are other families but um not so
important there. Okay.
What are on demand, reserved and spot
instances.
Now again this is related how you want
to buy or subscribe AWS services. For
example, you can subscribe EC2 instant
based on demand. Meaning pay only for
when you use EC2 instance otherwise not
only pay no commitment required whatever
you use pay for that like uh you hire a
cab to go somewhere and pay for the
travel driation only okay same way this
is on demand EC2 instance and that is
ideal for short-term or unpredictable
workloads. Okay. Second is reserved in
instance. Meaning for example you
pre-book a server for 1 2 3 years and
save money. The reserved EC2 instance is
best for steady and long-term use. Uh
like you hire a car for 6 months period.
So for that one-time payment is high.
But if you are using it continuously
then the ultimate cost will be low
right. So that is the reserved instance.
Last one is the spot instance. So
meaning buy unused capacity at huge
discount but this can be interrupted
anytime. For example, you booked a
shared cap for your travel which is very
low low cost but it can increase your
travel time and have some other problems
also because of other travelers in your
shared capab. So this
spot instance is great for flexibility
or batch jobs which are not active batch
jobs background jobs. Okay, because they
will happen in the background. So even
if they are interrupted still it is
okay, right? So great that is the answer
to this question and in the upcoming
question we will explore one of the most
used service in AWS which is very very
important. I will explain in upcoming
question.
What is AWS elastic beanto? For what
purpose can you use it?
If you are from a development background
then this is one of the top AWS service
you will use. Now if you remember IAS
which is stand for infrastructure as a
service then EC2 is the example of I is
meaning if you are using uh EC2 then you
are using is model of cloud because to
host application you will also install
the take care of many things which are
in I only. Okay. So EC2 you have to
manage many things. You have to install
the operating system. You have to for
application hosting. You have to install
the frameworks to host your application.
Many many things. But there is if you
remember pass which stands for platform
as a service then is this model. As a
developer you only need to provide the
application code data configuration and
nothing else. For this you do not have
to create the EC2 instance or configure
load balancer or manage the underlying
these this infrastructure. Okay. All of
them automatically handled by AWS. You
just need to create your web app API or
backend service front end and deploy it
using the elastic pin stack.
That's it. So whether you are building a
web app, a rest API, mobile back end,
you can use elastic pin stack of the
service of the AWS. Okay. And EBS lets
you deploy your application in the cloud
uh with few clicks only. It's the
simplest way to deploy or host your
application in AWS cloud. Here is the
simple and easy to remember definition.
AWS beanstack is a fully managed
platform as a service that enable
developers to deploy and scale also web
application and services without
managing the infrastructure.
Okay. So simple definition like this
will help you to revise easily uh from
the book before your interview so that
you don't forget the answers.
Now you may ask if Beantock is the right
choice, the best choice, simplest choice
for a hosting application then why we
have AC2.
Good question. So that I will explain in
the upcoming question. But yes, before
that I will explain some features of
bean stack uh so that you can easily
understand beanstack in a very complete
way and uh you will know that why beanto
is so popular. It is very popularly
used.
Before moving forward, a quick note
here. I created a complete AWS interview
preparation boot camp for you with three
powerful tools. Number three, 200 plus
AWS interview questions from all the
topics stepby step even for AWS
beginners like this. Second, a PDF book
for quick lastm minute revision. and
first 10 AWS mock interviews to practice
like real interviews. Many student have
already cracked interviews with my
courses. All links are in the
description. If interested, great. If
not, no worries. Let's move to the next
question. What are the five main
features or advantages of using stick
bean stack? Now by the end you will be
100% confident on bean stack stock. So I
already explained previously how EBS is
the pass okay service like this. Now to
dep deploy an application in AWS you
have two choices either you can use EC2
instance and manually set up your
application environment or second is use
elastic beanto which simplifies
everything. How it simplifies? Why it's
a great choice? Because of Beantock five
features. First feature is
it supports multiple programming
languages like .NET, Java, Python, Node,
PHP,
Ruby, Go. So no matter which tech stack
you are using in your application,
Beanstack can handle it automatically.
You don't have to install those
frameworks in your AWS environments.
Okay, it has automatic everything.
Second feature is built in auto
scalability. Uh meaning when traffic
increases or decreases, bean stack will
automatically adds or removes instances
behind the scene. You do not have to
worry about anything manually. You do
not have to uh nothing is required
basically. Okay. Very important feature
is third feature of beanstack is fully
managed environment. That means AWS
handles everything OS update security
maintenance everything patching
monitoring everything. So you just have
to focus on writing and deploying your
code on your on your first you're
writing your code and then deploying it
in few seconds with the help of bean
stack.
Fourth feature high availability elastic
bean stack is um integrated with load
balancers behind the scenes and auto
recovery. So even if one servers fails
uh so the but your app will be keep
running you do not have to worry about
that okay automatic load balancing and
last feature is secure and compliant
beanto can integrate with IM roles VPC
AWS certificate manager everything so
your application secured and follows AWS
best practices for authentication and
data protection.
In short, every tool and best practices
is already there. You have to deploy
your code using bean stack. Okay. So
that's the answer to this question. Now
you may ask if beanstack is so good then
why we need EC2 sometimes sometimes we
need EC2 also for hosting applications.
So when when when it is the case and
that I will explain in upcoming
questions. What is AWS Lambda function?
Have you ever used them in your project?
Very very important question from
interview point of view. Stay with me
till the end and then you can explain
this to anyone with example. Let's
understand with the help of an example.
Suppose you are uh a developer and your
development team has created a web
application in AWS. You have the front
end server built in Angular React.js.
This front end passes the request to the
back end or API server which can be int
net java or node and finally everything
connects to the database. Okay. So this
front end and back end can be in uh
hosted in EC2 instances or hosted in
using the elastic bean stock. So that
doesn't matter okay can be in anything.
Now imagine a user is signing up in your
application like this and during the
sign up the user is uploading a photo or
some any kind of image document.
That image document will be stored in
the Amazon S3 storage like this in AWS
cloud. Okay. It S3 is used to store
mainly the images. Okay. And I will
explain in detail in upcoming question
about the this S3. But uh now you know
it is in short used to store the files
and images of your application. Okay.
Now listen carefully. images are very
large in size and uh or maybe videos
very large in size and large image
require more space in S3 which means
more AWS cost for your company because
you are storing bigger files in S3.
Okay. Now as an AWS developer you uh
come up with a brilliant idea or a
solution to save cost of your company.
you used a service in AWS called AWS
Lambda. You created a lambda uh and
inside that lambda you will write some
code to compress the images. Okay. Now
what happens whenever the image is
uploaded in this Amazon S3 storage
bucket or account or storage
then a trigger will be fired and
automatically your lambda function and
the code inside it will be executed and
will compress the image and then it will
store the image. Getting my point?
Before storing the image, the impage
will be compressed in size by your code
which is written inside the lambda
function.
That means now you need less storage is
required in the S3 storage and your
company cost will be saved and that's a
great job and you will get the employee
of the month award for saving company
cost. So this is a very common use case
and if you will say this in the
interview then interviewer will think
that you have read it somewhere. Okay.
So here is one more example.
Suppose you want that as soon as a user
signs in like this uh a successful
welcome email should be sent to the user
automatically back to him. No manual
thing automatically.
For this also you can write a lambda
function which will be automatically
triggered as soon as a user will sign up
and it will uh the lambda function will
send the welcome email to the user.
That's it. Remember lambda function is
just a piece of code which is running
behind background. Okay.
Now I'm sure you are fully understood
the purpose of AWS Lambda right and here
is the simple easy to remember
definition
AWS Lambda is a serverless compute
service that lets you run code in
response to events. When something will
happen then your Lambda function will be
triggered. Okay, some event must happen
to trigger the Lambda function without
managing servers. basically managing
without managing servers. What is the
meaning of this? That I will explain you
in the upcoming question in detail.
Okay. So remember in short lambda
function will only execute when
something will happen and it is a piece
of code. All right. If this is fully
clear to you then write crystal clear in
the comments or chat. that will boost
your confidence and help you to never
forget this concept ever in your life.
Also this diagram and this definition in
the book will help you in quick revision
for your interviews from the book later.
Okay. Now in interview sometimes they
ask one indirect question. Okay. This is
the this is the first question. Now they
will ask why not just write the lambda
function code directly inside the main
application itself. Lambda function is
just a piece of code. Why not to write
inside the main application the same
code? And that's a great question and I
will answer that in the upcoming
question.
What exactly is serverless in AWS? Is it
truly serverless? Now you are going to
master this serverless. So I already
explained this use case of uh AWS Lambda
in the previous question and the biggest
advantage of Lambda is it is serverless.
Now listen carefully serverless doesn't
mean that there are no servers. Lambda
functions runs on some AWS server only
but it is called serverless means
because you do not have to manage that
server that server on which lambda
function is running. Okay, you will pay
for only for how many times your lambda
function is executed not for the server
uptime. Getting my point? So you do not
have to worry about anything about that
server like setting it up, maintaining
or anything. And also remember that your
main application might be running on EC2
or beantock
but lambda functions run separately and
independently on some separate server
which you do not have to manage. Okay.
So now you may ask what is the advantage
of being serverless?
So in AWS this lambda case lambda
function allows you to separate or
decouple some piece of logic from your
main application which you already know
and that is the benefit of the
serverless. It's a big benefit. Okay. So
let me give you an example. See nowadays
everything is moving towards decoupling
and loose coupling. For example earlier
we have that big monolithic applications
where front end, back end, logic, HTML,
Java, JavaScript everything was inside
one big application, right? And we call
them monolithic applications. Now we are
moving moving towards microervices.
a small small piece of independent
services independent which are loosely
coupled which are not dependent on each
other.
So that is the benefit of serverless
being independent. So because as
compared to a big tightly coupled
application a monolithic application
where you will do one change and you
have to test all the application big
application that's a great risk. So
these small small services are important
and AWS lambda will help you for doing
the same for decoupling the logic from
your main app. Okay.
Whatever logic can be run independently
like uh image compression, email
notification, data cleanup, you can put
that code inside lambda. So that is the
main reason behind the existence of the
AWS lambda and the same is the
importance of uh serverless and
independent services and same for
microservices.
All clear? Now here is the simple short
answer. Serverless in Azure means
running code without managing the
server. And the second part is it truly
serverless? No, it's not. servers still
exist but you don't manage them. Okay.
So that is the answer. Now you will ask
AWS Lambda is triggered by events right.
So what are those triggers?
What kind what type of are of those
triggers and that I will explain you in
the upcoming question.
What is Amazon RDS? How is it different
from the regular databases? Now if you
remember this pass category then for
applications you can host the
application in EC2 nor beanto or lambda
in a site. Similarly for data you can
use RDS for data RDS.
Okay here is one more very important
diagram where you can see our
applications are getting the data from
the RDS which is the database. Okay. Now
as a developer if you have used MySQL,
Oracle, SQL server etc. on your local
system
or in the onremise servers then Amazon
RDS is the same and the best RDBMS
database in AWS for you. You can use it
along with the Oracle or MySQL or any
database. Okay. So for database of your
uh if you want database for your
application select the RDS service in
AWS.
Here is the clear and short definition.
Amazon RDS is a fully managed
cloud-based relational database service
from AWS. It is offered as a platform as
a service meaning you just have to
provide the data the data struct uh
table structure whatever but you do not
have to install the Oracle or you do not
have to worry about the main
installations just you have to provide
the data to AWS and they will already
use RDS you have just to choose the RDS
service okay AWS will take care all for
managing the backups for you know
patching updates everything AWS will do
that's the diagram and that's the
definition and this definition diagram
will help you in the revision for your
interviews from this book
what is virtual private cloud VPC in AWS
why do we need it by the end you will
understand this 100%
imagine your company is hosting all its
applications using EC2 instances like
this and databases resources on the AWS
servers something like this. Okay,
everything I explained in the previous
questions all these resources
are used by your company. Now your
company wants all these resources must
be secured meaning they should not be
directly open to the internet and only
the internal resources or the approved
users should be able to access these
resources. Okay, all these resources
because if they are open to internet
then anyone from the outside can you
know access EC2 directly and can steal
your data can access your RDS.
So we don't want that right to avoid
this AWS gives you something called a
VPC which is which stands for virtual
private cloud. VPC is like your
company's own private network inside the
AWS cloud. Once your company server,
databases, other sites are inside the
web PC, you know, then they can talk to
each other. That's fine. But they are
not exposed to the internet to the
internet by default. Got it? So here is
the final and simple answer. A virtual
private cloud is a private network in
AWS where you can place your cloud
resources like EC2 instances, database,
anything.
And yes, AWS automatically creates this
VPC default VPC for each region. You
don't have to worry about this. Okay.
But yes, you can also create your own
VPC and you can customize it. But AWS
also provide you by default.
Now if you will I now you will ask if so
that's point I have written you here
that AWS automatically creates a default
VPC. Now you might ask if VPC by default
blocks internet access then how your web
applications which are hosted here uh or
in beantock are accessible to users from
outside via the internet right question
so I will explain that in the upcoming
question but with this diagram and this
definition later you can easily revise
for your interviews.
from this book, right?
What is the role of AWS elastic load
balancer? What are the types of load
balancers? Now, you are going to master
this concept. Let's say you are a
developer and you set up AWS cloud for
your company and then you are running
your applications in EC2 servers like
the front end on EC2 API and the
database like this. So as I explained
earlier when more users will visit your
website more and more so you will add
more EC2 instances like this by using
this horizontal scaling concepts which I
already explained in previous questions.
Right now here is the real question. how
the incoming traffic from multiple users
like this on the internet will be shared
equally between these uh EC2 servers.
How it is shared? Okay, for that we will
use AWS elastic load balancer. AWS
elastic balancer will act like a traffic
police or a traffic light. First it will
receive all the request and then it will
evenly distributes all the request
properly equally between the multiple
EC2 instances like this. Okay, it will
make sure that no EC2 instance will be
overloaded. Okay, it will distribute the
requests properly.
Here the simple easy to remember
definition. AWS load balancer
distributes incoming traffic across
multiple EC2 instance to ensure high
availability, scalability and fault
tolerance. Clear? Now there are four
types of elastic load balancers and the
one this one which I showed you right
now is called the network load balancer.
It is a type of elastic load balancer.
Okay. And here are the other types. We
have the network load balancer. Then we
have the application load balancer,
classic load balancer and gateway load
balancer.
So all these load balancers I will
explain you in the upcoming questions.
But this diagram and this definition
these types from the book will help you
in revision later. Right? So as I said
we have to distribute the load balancer
is primary for distributing the requests
properly. Okay.
What is AWS Route 53? How does it manage
global traffic? Let's understand this
100%. Imagine you are working as a lead
developer in a very big company like
Amazon or Microsoft and your application
is hosted globally in the AWS cloud.
Okay, for example, here you have uh one
set of EC2 instances like this in region
one, New York or any region. Okay, and
another set of EC22 instances are in
Mumbai. Okay. Similarly, you have users
who are accessing your applications from
USA and there are some users which are
accessing your applications from India.
Now you want that when the users are
sending requests from near USA users
those should be redirected to New York
region like this because New York region
is close to USA users and they will get
the response faster right for that you
can use Amazon Route 53 service like
this route 53 will receive all the
request
and distribute the request based on the
closest region. So here when users uh
from India will or near India will send
the request they will be redirected to
the Mumbai region. So AWS route 53
distributes user traffic based on the
location so that users uh request goes
to the nearest region and responses
faster. That is uh the role of route 53.
But yes, one more thing once the request
will reach this uh New York or Mumbai
region here you can set up the load
balancers. It is possible inside those
regions and then you can equally
distribute the um uh request between the
multiple EC2 instances. Okay. So that is
the full picture and real use case of
root 53 in real projects. And here is
the simple uh definition.
Route 53 is a DNS-based traffic rooting
service that distribute user request
across AWS regions based on you rules
like user locations or latency.
So what is the meaning of latency?
Location you understand latency. What is
the meaning of latency?
latency. For example, if region one,
this New York region suppose it is down
or it is slow for some time, then route
53 will redirect the USA users also to
the Mumbai region to the region 2
because region one New York is down that
also route 53 will manage and that is
the answer to this latency. Okay. So
this diagram and definition will help
you in revising the concept quickly from
this book. Now in the upcoming question
I will show you the what is subnet which
is which is like the kid or son of the
VPC only.
What is AWS IM identity and access
management?
Be ready after listening to this answer
you will be 100% confident on this
concept. Let's understand with the help
of an example. Suppose your company is
using AWS cloud and there are two
applications hosted inside it. One is a
email application and another one is the
payroll application. You are the
developer or architect managing this AWS
setup for your company. Okay. Now there
are three users trying to access these
apps. So a first is a regular employee.
User A regular employee of your company.
Second user B is someone who is the HR
of your company. Okay? He is also an
employee. And third is the user C which
is outside from your company not the
employee of your company. Okay? Now
listen carefully. As a AWS developer,
you you will take the help of AWS AM
okay identity and access management. You
will set up this service in your AWS
account to decide who can access which
application. For example, the email
application here. Okay. Both the user A
and user B, company employee and company
HR will be able to access but the user C
is unauthorized. He will will not be
able to access this email application.
Okay. Similarly for the payroll
application only and only the user B
only the HR will be able to access not
even user A because payroll will be
accessed by or you know distributor pay
will pay will be distributed by HR only.
Right? So that is how IM works. It
authenticates user to check who they are
and authorize them to give permission
what they can access. Okay. So basically
IM implement authentication and
authorization concepts. Remember this.
And yes, if you are confused between
authentication and authorization, don't
worry. I will explain this in upcoming
question. But before that, here is the
simple definition.
AWS IM is a secure cloud-based service
in AWS that helps organizations verify
users and control access to AWS services
and resources. So whatever services are
present in your AWS,
IM will control the access for them.
Okay. So in short, IM will not allow
unauthorized users to access your AWS
applications. That's it. And this
diagram and this definition in this book
will help you in doing the quick
revision before your interviews. What is
a CI/CD pipeline in AWS how you have
used in your project. Now if you have
some experience as a developer then you
already know these steps involved in
creating an application. First you plan
then code, build, test, release, deploy
and then finally operate or monitor the
application in production. So that is
the normal application life cycle. Now
what is CI? CI means continuous
integration.
It simply means let's say you are a
developer and you write some code for a
new feature. you push your code to some
shared place like github or AWS code
commit. So at the same time your
teammates are also writing and pushing
their code right. So here comes this
this integration process continuous
integration. As soon as you push the
code an automatic process start which is
by a tool called uh AWS code build.
First it will check whether your code
will build properly. No compile time
error. When build is successful this
build point. When build is successful it
automatically runs the unit tests. Okay.
If it passes all the test then only your
code will be accepted and added to the
main branch of your project. Okay. So
that is the continuous integration
because you are continuously publishing
code every day to the main branch. Okay.
So that process is automatic that why
that's why its name is continuous
integration. You also keep working on
new items in parallel and continuously
pushing the code for integration. Right?
And yes as I said if there is any build
error or any test will fail first you
have to fix those and then only your
code will be merged to the main branch.
Now second points comes CD. What is
continuous deployment? It means the code
from the main git branch is
automatically deployed to different
different environments like dev QA or
staging using a tool uh like AWS code
deploy or AWS code pipeline. Okay. So
it's like this. So com the continuous
code is coming you are pushing the code
and that pushed code is released deploy
operate again and again again again and
again in a cycle like this that's why
its name is continuous continuous
deployment because from the source code
is continuously deployed by the infra or
devops team in the production or QA
servers whatever servers
and of course before pushing to
production you can add manual approvals
from the QA team manager or other uh
gate gates in the pipeline. In short,
CI/CD pipeline in AWS helps to automate
your entire project flow like this from
coding in development to production
making everything faster and smoother
and simpler. Okay, that's the answer to
this question. And finally, here is the
definition. A CI/CD pipeline is an
automated process
used by developers and DevOps teams to
build, test and deploy code quickly and
reliably.
Now you will ask what are the tools used
by AWS team to perform these steps of
CI/CD pipelines and that I will cover in
upcoming question.
What is Amazon Cloudatch? How does it
help developers? After hearing this, you
can explain this concept to anyone.
Let's say you are a developer and you
have developed your application and
deployed it to the production
environment in AWS. Now user will start
using your application. But as a
developer, you want to keep an eye on
how the application is performing. For
example, are users facing any errors or
is the app sometimes slowing down or
having any latency issues? When exactly
the app is slowing down or what features
of your applications are being used the
most by the users. So to monitor all
these in one place, AWS gives you this
powerful tool called Amazon Cloudatch.
Okay, Cloudatch mainly provides two
things to to you. One is matrix and one
is log. This is the diagram. Matrix will
basically show you the performance
numbers like how much is the CPU usage
by your application, how much is the
memory usage of your application or how
many request your application is
receiving basically request count. So
all these performance numbers in short
matrix is all about numbers. So that
later by checking these numbers you can
analyze the overall performance of your
application.
Second thing after matrix is logs. Logs
if you are a developer you already know
uh what actually log is like what
actually happening behind the scenes.
For example, if a user has encountered
some error while using your application,
then that error will be logged with the
information and by the help of the
cloudatch as a developer you can see
that error message and in a very good
way and for that cloudatch will provide
you many tools. Okay, then you can fix
that problem uh error and then you can
you know uh deploy the new solution
also cloudatch does not just show you
the data or just display the data. It
also help you to take the actions also.
For example, you can use the cloud the
these are the features you can use the
cloudatch alarms to get the automatic
alerts when something goes wrongs. For
example, if sometime your application is
taking high CPU usage or spike, then
that's an error. Then cloudatch will can
send you the alerts or alarms like in
email or if user encountered any error
then also cloudatch can send you the
email. Okay. So there are many more
features of cloudatch like cloudatch
dashboards then which will show you the
key metrics visually on a screen. Then
you can use the cloudatch logs insights
to search and analyze logs quickly using
very simple queries. Then you can also
connect cloudatch with other tools like
Amazon quicksite to generate reports and
make smarter business or you know
technical decision. You can take
decision based on those reports.
In short, Cloudatch and its tools help
developers
monitor, troubleshoot and improve
application performance and that is all
in the real time. That's it. Finally,
here is the definition of Cloudatch.
Cloudatch is a monitoring service that
collects, analyze, and visualize the
performance, the data, logs, and metrics
from your AWS application and
infrastructure.
That is the answer to this question. And
now you will never forget this. But yes,
in case you forget, then this definition
and diagram in the book will help you in
quick revision.
Now the cloudatch is like a big
container and it has many tools inside
it which helps developers in analyzing
the application. One of the popular tool
is Amazon Cloudatch application insight
and that I will explain in upcoming
question.
Great job my friend. Most will just talk
but the way you finished this video
shows your seriousness and dedication
towards your goal. Now if you understand
these questions then there are slightly
more complex questions also like SQS,
NS, SNS, CloudFront, DLQ and others
which are also very important and asked
in interviews. All I have explained in
my complete AWS interview boot camp.
Many of my students have already used my
courses to crack their interviews. Now,
if you don't want to miss a single
question for your next interview, then
check out the boot camp and book link in
the description below.